that's right Iowa on taxes and spending
if Rick Santorum wins you lose I'm Rick
Perry and I perfect Mitt Romney because
it's time we start believing in America
again paid for by rick santorum for
president i'm rick santorum and I
approve this message my freedom back
just get the government yeah the
interesting about ron paul fans that i
found is whatever hooks them first and i
tell you the two main things that tend
to hook them first are the the federal
reserve currency issues or the foreign
policy stuff retired military veteran
like a 20 years army air force I've been
an enlisted guy I've been an officer I
support Ron Paul because he's the only
one that's talking about not getting
into a war I think I think a lot of
people overlook the fret of the Fed I
mean I think the money's money can print
as much as we want but really he's a
real person and he offers real solutions
he he spells it out pretty bluntly when
he says he's gonna cut a trillion
dollars in the first year and once
they're hooked in almost universally
they decide that they like everything
about him all of the candidates be they
Obama Democrat or any of the other
Republican candidates are often the same
mark I honestly can't see any of the
other candidates being as principled as
he is and for all the work he's done
over the years for being principled for
this country I want to be principled
back and I'm gonna vote principle no
matter what I I think this is what leads
people to talk about like the Ron Paul
cult of personality but I don't think
it's a cult of personality I think it's
actually a cult of reason like they he
hooks them so they start listening to
him and then they find hey he makes
sense not just on this one issue but
this you know overall picture of Liberty
and live in a government we had the
freest country the most prosperous
country the biggest no class
ever but the middle class is shrinking
everybody knows it I think we will get
first place I don't know if it's going
to be a huge landslide or it's coming
close but I think that we've got the
best ground game here in Iowa and I
think we've got by far the most
enthusiasm and most importantly we've
got the best candidate one Paul I
definitely expect Ron Paul to come in
over 20 absolutely he's going to come in
a strong second and a win is definitely
still a possibility I'm keeping my
distance I think we may have some
dramatic good news for tomorrow night